In the home screen I can
click on Settings and
then click on Accessibility and click
on TalkBack and switch TalkBack on.
>> TalkBack on.
Settings.
>> I can also go to the settings for
TalkBack and double tap to select it.
Showing items 1 to 9 of 33.
>> To scroll I can use two fingers.
I'm going to scroll down the page here,
there is a little tutorial,
>> Showing items 19 to,
launch explore by touch tutorial.
>> I highly recommend
you check this out.
>> Overview button, overview settings,
Chrome the accessibility blog, Chrome.
>> As I was taking a look
at our accessibility blog,
>> The accessibility blog.
>> We can explore by touch.
Swipe, just switch to
different headings.
>> Topics.
Sample blog post.
Double tap to select.
>> And when we find something that we're
interested in, we can highlight it and
double tap it to select it.